wo ist dein weg
tschüss ihr leben der fisch war sehr
lecker das freut uns die wm das nächste
jahrhundert fußball ja ich dann vom
freitag dem 19
wir sehen uns am freitag um 2 ja was
muss ein bankkaufmann machen
ein bankkaufmann geld zehn jahre als
werden muss ein bankkaufmann auch geld
zählen und ein bankkaufmann muss kunden
beraten er muss finanzen überprüfen und
termine mit kunden organisieren
es ist viel büroarbeit büroarbeit
büroarbeit
du musst zum beispiel e-mails schreiben
und verträge unterschreiben und
natürlich immer schön freundlich sein
das müssen wir im restaurant ja wenn ich
immer und ein elektriker ein elektriker
muss älter installieren oder repariert
etwas das klingt cool das ist der song
aber max hat recht hier sind wir die
chefs das ist besser das mache ich ja
wir müssen viel arbeiten aber die arbeit
ist super cool ist das denn
nein es ist lisas machen die braucht sie
ja na los bringt dieser die mappe